Listen, I have a question cuz me and my
friend uh came across this verse. Uh
it's first John 5:7.
>> First John, there are three that bear
from heaven, the father, the word, the
holy spirit. These three are one.
>> Yes. And I heard arguments against it
that it has been added to the Bible.
What what can you say about this? There
is some dispute
concerning New Testament textual critics
regarding 1 John 5:7 because it is found
in late Greek copies of 1 John 5 that
have the verse meaning the verses
in which
you find 1 John chapter 5
that have verse 7 are very late. They
come from the medieval time period like
1500s and sometimes it's found in the
marginal note because there aren't early
Greek copies of first John 5 that have
that verse. It's not there. Textual
critics say that this is a scribal note
that was later added to the text and
they reject it. You want me there?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Now the problem with that claim is
it is found
in
Latin copies of 1 John 5. It was
included by St. Jerome in his Latin
Vulgate even though some copies of the
Latin Vulgate omitted it. Nonetheless,
there is evidence coming from the
western church, the Latin speaking
church, and there are copies of first
John 5 in Latin that have the verse that
are very ancient.
>> Yes, I I had I heard about this
actually.
>> So, but if you prioritize Greek copy
because number one, we don't have all
the Greek copies of First John 5 ever
written. So, we do not know whether
There were early Greek copies that would
have verse 7 because we don't have all
those copies. You see, you can only
judge by the copies you have. And the
Greek copies that would have first John
that include verse 7 are later
from let's say 1500s. And there is a
scribal node and a column that may be a
little earlier but that's it. But the
problem again I'm repeating it the
problem again is that's based on the
evidence we have. We don't have every
copy of 1 John 5 written in Greek in
existence. Much of those copies have
vanished
because of this. This is why scholars
don't accept it. But if you believe the
Latin copies were based on Greek
manuscripts,
for the Latin to have first John 5:7
means that the Greek copy that they used
to translate the Greek into Latin must
have had that verse. And one of our
earliest witnesses to 1 John 5:7 is St.
Cyprien because he cites it as something
written in his Latin Bible and if he's
quoting first John 5:7 in the early 200s
that means that Latin was based on Greek
copies that came in the second century.
See how it works?
>> Okay. So it's actually quite
understandable to be honest.
>> Yeah. I even have some articles on this
cuz I actually accept it as genuine. The
only problem is that I don't use it
because I don't have time to argue for
its veracity.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I understand. I understand.
>> Okay. Here, I'll show you the right
here. Here he goes. Latin witness. Where
is John? Right here. Here it is.
>> Oh,
>> so I'm going to give it to you. So you
understand what he's asking me guys. 1
John 5:7, Dewey Reigns, King James, New
King James, modern English version have
there are three that bear record in
heaven. The father, the word, the holy
ghost, the holy spirit. These three are
one.
Your modern versions won't have that.
They'll relegate it to a footnote. So,
we're going to go into it. I'm going to
give you the evidence. I just sent this
to you in private chat.
>> Okay. Now, let's go into the versions.
Okay. Watch here. You guys Catholics, do
you know it's in your dewy range? Why?
Because we have pre preface of St. Rome
to the Catholic epistles where he
comments that 1 John 5:7 there are three
that work in heaven, father, word, and
holy spirit. These are one. He actually
included it in 1 John 5, which means he
found it in the Greek copies that he was
using to produce Latin Vulgate. Some
later Latin
Vulgate manuscripts didn't have it, but
many do. So, watch what I'm talking
about.
You guys okay with me going through this
as I trust the spirit to give me clarity
of thought and speech, perfect recall,
and destroy any mistakes I make? You
guys learning? All right. Now,
let's go here. Watch the difference. For
there are three that bear record in
heaven. The father, the word, and the
holy ghost. These three are one.
American standard version doesn't have
it.
And it is the spirit that beareth
witness because the spirit is the truth.
Amplified for there are three witnesses
doesn't have it. Now here they put
italics. Italiciz meaning they don't
believe it's original. This is based on
King James. CSV doesn't have it. Look
all the Bibles that don't have it here.
Catholics Dewey Reigns has it.
Your Dewey Reigns English translation
has it. And John had and the hadock is
his name John. Father John had I
produced his commentary on 1 John 5:7
where this outstanding Cath Catholic
Bible exags
authenticity. I'll give you the link to
that in a minute.
Here it is. There are three who give
testimony in heaven. The father, the
word, and the holy ghost. And these
three are one.
Now to make it easy for you, I'm just
going to show you some footnotes what
they say about this verse. Okay. Right
here.
[music]
>> Sorry, bro.
>> Well, I'm sorry that I exist because I
just disturbed your flow. What was it?
>> It was my computer.
>> Your who?
>> I I I click I clicked something.
>> No way. The com comforter.
>> No, my computer, brother.
>> Okay. I thought this is
>> Sorry. Sorry for my accent.
>> No, I love your accent. It's very, very
gorgeous. You can get a lot of godly
woman, but you can only have one. You
can't have more than one. Okay.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Remember, as Christians, one man, one
woman, make sure she's the one because
you can't have three or four. So, don't
use your accent to try to get women's
mouth
>> because you sound like Rico Suave.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
>> Okay. Watch here.
>> You following me so far?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Here's a footnote. Look, Christian
Standard Bible in verse 7, they don't
have there are three that bear work in
heaven, the father, the word, the holy
spirit. These three are one. Here's
their note. What
[clears throat and snorts] did I do
here? Shoot, man. Can you keep a secret,
brother?
>> Yeah.
>> So, can I now watch here?
A few late Greek manuscripts and some
late revolgate manuscripts at testify in
heaven. The father, [clears throat] the
word, and the holy spirit. These three
are one. Notice late. That's why they
don't accept it. All right. Now, let's
look at two more and then we're going to
go into some evidence that I believe is
strong enough to get you to accept it.
Okay?
Notice for there are three that testify.
That's it. But now watch here. Late
manuscripts of the Vulgate testify in
heaven. The Father, the Word, and the
Holy Spirit. And these three are one.
And there are three that testify on
earth. not found in any Greek manuscript
before the 14th century. You see?
>> Yeah.
>> See what they're telling you? All right.
Now, that's what they tell you. But what
they don't show you is other evidence
that shows that it was a reading known
to St. Cyprien whom who quoted it. So,
I'm going to get you my article on that
right here. But before I do that, let me
show you the commentary.
Haddock. Is his name father John
Haddock?
Muhammad. Here you go.
and it's on my blog as well.
He defends the authenticity of this
verse. Why? Because he follows the Latin
Vulgate and the Latin Vulgate based on
Dra has it. See it?
>> Yeah.
>> So, let me get you the links to this.
Now, watch here.
Object that this verse is wanting in
many Greek manuscripts and even Arasmus
in one edition
and Mr. Simon and his critics have
questioned it. Now watch or rejected it
as a false reading but without any
sufficient proofs and grounds as had
been shown by many learned Catholics.
Now Catholics watch how liberal critical
anti-trinitarian scholarship that arose
from Protestantism. So sinians were
Protestants. Miguel Cervettos, Michael
Cervides, Protestants
has poisoned the Catholic Church because
right now your Catholic Bibles reject 1
John 5:7
also by Protestant writers who receive
in their translations versus Kanako. So
learned Catholics and Protestants accept
it. It is easy to count for the mission
of this verse. For as both the seventh
and eth verse begin and end with the
same words, this gave occasion to the
oversight and omission of the
transcribers because verse seven and 8
have similar warnings. So it's easy for
the eye to skip over to verse 8.
Whereas it is not credible that such a
whole verse could be added and that it
was only by the mistaken oversight of
transa transcribers may further appear.
Look at the evidence he brings because
we find part of the seven verses to it.
These are one cited by Tertullian
against Proxius
right twice by Cyprien and it's in my
other article
right and his adanum
and his treatis
uni I guess ecclesia
right where also Dr. Fel defends this
verse of St. John to be genuine.
Tertillian Cyprien wrote long before
dispute with Aryans and they allude to
it and other Latin writers and fathers
cited St. Fentius
made use of it against the Aryans and
also others about that time. Even St.
Jerome included it. Both Catholics and
Protestants after diligent examination
have received this verse which is found
in the best manuscripts.
You got it.
I'm going to shock you.
Even the reformers,
even the reformers
accepted 1 John 5:7 as genuine
scripture. Now, here are the Latin
witnesses. So, you can go here, but here
here it is. St. Cyprien, he cites it.
If of the Holy Spirit, since the three
are one, you only find that in 1 John
5:7. But this is not as explicit. This
is explicit.
He's quoting what is written. Cyprien of
Carthage. The Lord says, I and the
father one. That's John 10:30. And
again, it is written of the Father and
the Son and the Holy Spirit. These three
are one. The only place you're going to
find where it's written there are one is
1 John 5:7.
You should see how many people
try to argue against St. Cyprien
quoting 1 John 5:7. They said, "No, he's
not quoting the Father and the Word and
the Holy Spirit are one." He's referring
to something else that symbolizes them.
You see that? They won't let the
evidence speak for itself. They have to
explain it away.
Fortunately, there have been many who do
believe that Cyprin is quoting 1 John
5:7, father and word, the Holy Spirit.
These three are one. And I give you the
receipts here.
I give you the receipts here. So I don't
need to go on all this. And I give you
others. People quoting this verse 3rd
century, fourth century, fifth century,
but mostly from the Latin stream, the
Latin fathers and apologists
being genuine, being part of first John
5. It's right there.
All there. So I don't need to belabor
the point. So brother, I do accept it.
Fulgentius
I believe there's early evidence enough
evidence to show that the Latin is
getting it from the Greek. So if
Cyprien's quoting it in Latin and the
3rd century 200s that means the Latin's
based on a Greek text that comes from
the 2 century.
Even St. Jerome mentions in his
introduction to the Catholic epistles
this verse and he accepts it as genuine.
Here's another one. Priscilian who
quotes it.
Vigilius Tapansi quotes it. The Council
of Carthage quoted it against the
Aryans.
You get it?
And on top of that, brother, you know
who else quotes it as genuine scripture?
The Protestant Reformers. Here it is
right here. If you click on it,
Protestant reformers,
if you go to John 7:53,
if you're going to see who quotes 1 John
5:7, I'm sorry, as genuine. John Kelvin,
he says, "There is some dispute, but
according to him,
there were sufficient Greek witnesses
that had the verse." I'm not going to
read the details for you. Since however
the passive flow is better when this
clause is added and as I see it it is
found in the best and most this is John
Kelvin
the best and most approved copies of the
Greek that means there were Greek copies
they had that had the verse that are not
in existence anymore.
Okay. John Gil accepts it as genuine.
Right. Francis Turin accepted and saying
that the best and most accurate Greek
copies that we have have the verse. Now
what does that mean? There were Greek
copies
they had access to that had the verse
that did not remain that they simply
disappeared from use. All right. But
anyway, I hope that answered your
question, brother.
>> Yes, brother. Thank you for clearing
that up for me. And yeah, thank you and
stay prayed up, stay blessed, brother.
Uh, Holy Mary, pray for us. Uh and yeah,
goodbye.